it sounds paradoxical to talk of the
problems of being beautiful when we're
so alive to all the advantages but oddly
being beautiful isn't problem-free there
are a range of ailments to little
discussed that go with being extremely
beautiful and that we should all perhaps
know a bit more about here are some of
the greatest the likelihood of having
nothing to say is so high because since
you were 12 you've never had to begin a
conversation they had to crack the jokes
just for the pleasure of seeing you
smile indeed you often wanted to put
people off being a bit boring has been a
sort of survival strategy it's the only
way to stop people pestering you in bed
you're always wondering is it me or is
it my body they want you want to be
loved for the whole of who you are but
your exterior is so fantastic it
overshadows anything else you want to be
appreciated for your take on the French
novel your loyalty to your troubled
sister your views on the future of the
left but even when people say the right
things the fears won't go away they make
too much sense
they don't wait to find out their
imaginations simply refuse to picture
you carefully I'm picking a page of
Plato or analyzing the state of a
Swedish economy they like the idea of
you being a bit dim you can't be that
beautiful and understand nuclear physics
that would be too much good fortune
ending up in one place everyone insists
you can't be very intelligent
fortune people feel has smiled on you
already
you can't need anything and that's why
they hate you a fair few people just
like finding fault with you they feel
you need to be shown that you're nothing
special although you never claimed to be
they're using you to vent their
frustrations with life in general you're
fair game you're too beautiful they
think ever to be hurt
you have this rare thing your body is
ideal for now that's why getting old
that terrifies you a lot yes sir you
found another wrinkle your left knee
twinges when you climb the stairs you
have so much to lose you look in the
mirror and foresee a wreck from being so
high the fall will be harder
fortunately the problems are being very
beautiful a transient thankfully no
one's dazed at the peak of loveliness
for long time we'll take your troubles
away in a few years almost certainly
your looks will have lost their uncanny
perfection your physique will shed its
grace
you'll be nice enough looking but you
will no longer be one of the
outstandingly attractive ones and you'll
no longer share and their unique but
very real and very underappreciated
problems
you